las nuevas instalaciones de khan academy
se encuentran en la bebida matemáticas
314 el edificio tiene 200 ventanas y 7
pisos el estacionamiento tiene capacidad
para 90 automóviles y el edificio mide
63 metros de alto cuál es la altura de
cada piso vamos a ir eliminando primero
la información que no nos funciona y
vamos poco a poco nos dice que está en
la avenida matemáticas 314 realmente
esto no nos da información para saber
cuál es la altura de cada piso nos dice
también que el edificio tiene 200
ventanas
y eso no nos funciona para saber la
altura de cada piso sin embargo nos dice
que tiene siete pisos esto sí es
información importante el
estacionamiento tiene capacidad para 90
automóviles eso está increíble pero
tampoco nos da información respecto a la
altura de cada piso o que nos ayude a
sacarla y finalmente el edificio mide 63
metros de alto esto sí es información
importante 63 metros de alto vamos a
marcarlo aquí vamos entonces a resolver
esta pregunta cuál es la altura de cada
piso y tomando la información que
tenemos nos dice que hay siete pisos
vamos a marcar de aquí
el techo a la planta baja tenemos siete
pisos
siete pisos contando la planta baja
tenemos siete pisos en este edificio el
edificio mide en total 63
metros
como utilizaremos esta información para
saber cuál es la altura de cada piso
pues muy sencillo
tendremos que el total de la altura que
son 63 metros será igual
cada uno
de estos pisos
por su altura sin embargo no tenemos la
altura esa es la que vamos a sacar así
es que tendremos aquí una incógnita
y será resuelta si nosotros dividimos 63
metros totales entre
los siete pisos que tenemos registrados
esto nos dará la altura de cada piso
estamos de acuerdo es exactamente la
misma información vista como
multiplicación y como división para
nosotros es muy sencillo ahora dado que
sabemos las tablas de multiplicar y
cuando vemos aquí un signo de
multiplicación sabemos que el producto
de estos dos enteros nos dará 63 así es
que podemos hacer la tabla de
multiplicar del 7
y haremos aquí
y haremos nuestra tabla en la que
multiplicaremos el siete por uno por dos
por tres por cuatro por cinco por seis
por siete por ocho por nueve y por diez
en alguno de estos puntos nos dará
nuestro resultado así es que vamos poco
a poco 7 por 17 7 por 2 14 7 por 3 21 se
dan cuenta simplemente estamos
aumentando
de siete en siete en cada uno de estos
avances
así es que podemos seguir 7 por 4 28 7
por 5 35 7 por 6 42 7 por 7 sumamos las
7 el 42 y tenemos 49 7 por 8 49 7 serán
7 x 9 63 7 x 10 70 y justo aquí tenemos
el resultado lo ven tenemos 63 nuestra
operación dice que 7
por 9
será igual a 63 que de hecho es la
altura que tenemos en el edificio eso
implica que este incógnita es igual am
por lo tanto cada piso medirá 9 metros
como podemos comprobarlo pues muy
sencillo aquí vamos a medir si cada uno
de estos pisos mide 9 tendremos aquí 9
metros al final del primer piso 18 al
final del segundo
27 al final del tercero
36 al final del cuarto estamos sumando
de 99 porque cada piso mide 99 de este
piso 9 de este piso 9 de este piso y así
vamos acumulando los al final del quinto
piso tendremos 45 metros al final del
sexto piso tendremos 54 metros y
finalmente
hasta el techo tendremos 63 metros con
eso tenemos entonces nuestra respuesta
correcta
cuál es la altura de cada piso la altura
de cada piso será 9 metros